FEMALE SPEAKER: Talk to me.
PAUL: Talking.
Sorry.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Yeah, that's better.
I think it's just the cable.
OK, cheers.
PAUL: Bit of a Kurt Russell.
He was in "Fast and Furious 7."
JAKE: Kurt Russell?
PAUL: He's in that,
and he's amazing.
He's doing that Robert
Redford thing, where--
JAKE: I can't remember,
because you told me
which "Fast and Furious" was.
I can't remember
what it was like.
PAUL: Right.
The "Fast and Furious" thing--
JAKE: Divorced, beheaded--
PAUL: It's not all the different
wives of "Henry VIII," no.
One, definitely.
Two, but you ignore the
third, which is "Tokyo Drift."
So you just ignore
that for a second.
Four, five, and then do three.
But I should have said, the last
bit of five-- no, sorry, six.
You do four, five, six--
JAKE: This is like trying to
understand the offside rule.
PAUL: Just watch them in order.
JAKE: I watch one-- watch
one and two, then one again--
PAUL: Four, five--
JAKE: I watch three, but
with the subtitles of five
over the top, and then
"Dark Side of the Moon"
playing in the background.
PAUL: If I'm honest,
I don't think you're
taking this seriously, Jake.
Anyway, let's talk
about something else.
The web.
JAKE: The web.
[MUSIC PLAYING]